hace algún tiempo leí que a largo plazo
únicamente nos acordamos del 20 por
ciento de las cosas es como una especie
de alzheimer colectivo que a todos nos
va a pasar en eso le dice como cuando en
internet ves que no te puedes topar el
codo lo intenté y entonces empecé a
recordar empecé a recordar lo que no
quería que se me olvidará la primera vez
que fue un estado de fútbol la primera
vez que fui a un avión la primera vez
que fue al mar
todos tenemos esas cosas que no queremos
que se nos olviden entonces también me
llegaron cosas útiles de la cabeza como
cervical dorsal lumbar sacro y coxis no
sé para qué lo tengo pero bueno eso sí
se me olvidan no hay problema si se
olvida también me acordé de cuando
platiqué con jose jose no no le entendí
mucho pero siempre que me acuerdo de eso
esto se vería en el corazón y entonces
eso es algo muy bueno
después me empezaron a llegar muchos
recuerdos a la cabeza y me acuerdo que
cuando era chico mi papá siempre llegaba
a la casa para ver la televisión y
siempre le gustaba tomar refresco
entonces pues tenía siempre su refresco
en el buró pero no siempre tiene un vaso
y le decía siempre a mi hermano ve por
un vaso ve por un vaso ve por un vaso
hasta que un día inició porque no va él
o sea yo
pues porque estamos viendo la tele
y entonces mi hermano y mi papá nos
voltea a ver me voltea a ver y me dice
porque se le va a caer
y entonces yo dije claro que no es un
diario traigo traigo todos mis vasos y
subasta los platos pero no lo dije
porque si no no me podía seguir viendo
la tele
entonces
me callé y dije aun puedas hacer las
cosas nadie va a esperar nada de ti y
esa es la primer gran ventaja de la
desventaja cualquier cosa que tú estás
en desventaja la gente espera que no lo
puedas hacer aunque lo puedas hacer y si
no esperan nada de ti te quitan muchos
kilos y te dan más tiempo para ver la
tele
y entonces
llegué después de eso ya había aprendido
una gran lección desde chiquitito nadie
ve esperar nada de ti y eso está muy
bien
después me metieron al kinder al que
estaba más cerca de mi casa porque es la
mejor escuela es la que está más cerca
de tu casa era un kinder convencional y
entonces ahí si te metes en un problema
porque ni están sus papás para
defenderte ni tu hermano para dejarse
ganar están 30 chamacos que todos se va
a ir se van en contra de ti a
preguntarte qué pasó porque eres
diferente entonces ahí aprendí la
segunda gran ventaja de la desventaja o
eres buen pedo no vales madre o sea
tienes que ser buena persona
y estoy pongamos un ejemplo si tu eres
estrictamente feo
a ver a quién te liga si eres mala
persona o si nunca tienes dinero y te
gusta salir de fiesta
si eres mala persona a ver quién te
invita en cambio si eres buena persona
te invitan aunque no pongas van las
chicas
si un día pones aunque sea 100 pesos ese
diario es un crack porque nadie esperaba
un centavo aunque los demás pongan 300
tú ya pusiste 100 y es un lujo
y entonces ahí ya yo ya había aprendido
dos cosas
nadie va a esperar nada de ti y eso está
muy bien otra tienes que ser buena
persona a la vez que es buena persona ya
logras muchas cosas porque
pues es buena persona no lo corras
aunque no lo inteligente y de ahí yo
acabé el kínder acabé la primaria y
acabé hasta la secundaria que es gran
cosa y en eso me vino otro recuerdo a la
mente una fuimos a un centro comercial
donde había muchos
y cosas de comer y las mesas del centro
yo pedí de comer me dieron mi charola
volteo y mi familia estaba en el piso de
arriba yo tenía que subir unas escaleras
eléctricas que eso entonces es complejo
entonces agarré la charola
puse un que puse el otro puse mi mano en
el barandal iba subiendo
así es como la escalera se va comiendo
así con los dientes de arriba volteas
para atrás y dos como cuarenta patronos
de la buena muerte y este
y en eso yo pones un pie así como un
delantero en la luna pones el otro y en
lugar de pisar la luna se te cae la
echaron
y entonces ahí yo aprendí muchas cosas
porque cada que te pasa algo aprendes
yo aprendí que tenía que volver a pagar
con si no me va a comer aprendí que
tenía que pedir las cosas para llevar
y aprendí para que no era bueno y esa es
la tercer gran ventaja de la desventaja
cuando eres medianamente bueno
medianamente malo dices no va yo lo voy
a intentar todo se puede detallar no y
estos vives la vida intentando algo para
lo que nunca vas a llegar o puede que sí
pero pero es muy difícil pero si eres
estrictamente malo
sabes que no vas a llegar yo sabía que
en méxico había perdido un grande cero
mi siguiente tarea era saber para qué
era bueno y la vida siempre te va
poniendo como las cosas que tienes que
saber y entonces yo llegué a una semana
vocacional en la escuela y me llevaron a
una fábrica de botanas en toluca y era
como willy wonka región 4 kristen y es
la gran cosa y botanas gratis y entonces
al final que se acaba
el recorrido y ves todo lo que hay ahí
dices yo quiero trabajar aquí entonces
íbamos caminando hasta el final yo me
quedé hasta el final de la fila iba a
correr un amigo y entonces veo a alguien
salir de la oficina y le dijo éste es mi
chance y qué se necesita para trabajar
aquí me dice pues la mayoría son
ingenieros
no ha de ser tan difícil porque mi papá
y mi hermano son ingenieros ese es una
chance no
entonces de ahí vaya apuntando y pasó
pasaron los días esto me gusta mucho el
fútbol estudié comunicación y empecé a
trabajar en eso después vi que no era lo
suficientemente bueno y dije si no son
lo suficientemente bueno y no voy a
llegar
ya no lo voy a intentar entonces me
empecé a dedicar a la insurrección
social buscando para ver para qué si
servía y entonces una vez un vecino mío
me dice oye necesito alguien como tú
para un trabajo
y digo inteligente y guapo mira y
entonces pues ya ni se mete en
entrevista te con este señor y a ver qué
tal y entonces yo dije si me pagan tanto
dinero me quedé me dice mi mamá te
paguen lo que te paguen te quedas tengo
una cuerda que para ahorcar te y
entonces yo ya voy a un lugar me
entrevistan lo convencí
y salgo y dice la señora a poco así lo
van a contratar ejecutaban y me puse
traje no
y entonces agarre y dije o reclamo o me
espero que nadie va a esperar nada de mí
y dije eso está mejor porque por lo
menos ya me tienen aquí tres veces de
prueba y cobras tulane
y entonces
o sea firme y salí de esa dehesa de esa
puerta volteo para atrás y es la misma
oficina de la que había salido esa
señora 13 años antes y yo le había
preguntado qué se necesitaba para
trabajar ahí después me di cuenta que no
se necesitaba ser ingeniero y que con
que te pusieras corbata en la planta te
decían ingeniero entonces la corbata te
ahorraba cinco años de estudiar
ingeniería
mi trabajo convencía básicamente en
contar lana de los empleados la empresa
la duplicada ayuda entregar cheques como
chabelo hacia diferentes fundaciones
esto es una vez de alto estrés en la
oficina llega a su ser español y así y
llegó aumentando madres 17 y tula de
comunicación le dice el único feliz en
esta oficina es juan pablo y le dice
claro si no único que hace regalar
nuestro dinero
y les digo bueno pero te convencí para
que me lo diera y entonces me di cuenta
que para eso era bueno
y entonces aquí le tengo que meter
porque porque si no me tengo que
conseguir algo de adeveras y entonces
empezó empezó a pasar el tiempo
y te das cuenta que eres bueno y yo fue
entregaron los cheques y después regresé
y era lo único que hacía y la verdad es
que era un trabajo complicado pedirla en
ajena pero pero pero era relativamente
sencilla la de comunicación me dice hoy
no te da así algo que nomás te hayan
contratado para entregar cheques digo
pues no dioses y nelson mandela no lo
hubieran llevado preso pues no hubiera
arreglado áfrica sin margen nuestro
quien no hubiera sido negro con todos
los temas que tuvo no hubiera arreglado
el tema en estados unidos y un si yo no
hubiera estado como tal me tendría que
haber conseguido un trabajo de adeveras
digo no está bien pero como siempre
cuando todo va bien llegó un punto en
que dices ya me dio esto fue como unos
dos años y yo dije algo tengo que hacer
y entonces fui con mi jefa que es una
persona muy muy muy elevada que es como
mi gurú y le dije oye qué tengo que
hacer y me puse estudiar estudiar una
maestría digo berduc con lo que me pagas
aquí
y entonces que alcanzado para pagar la
renta pero pero no pagar una maestría
entonces yo agarré y me busque un
trabajo de adeveras para una segunda
segunda oportunidad porque aquí ya había
aprendido y si bien nadie esperaba nada
de mí yo sí esperaba y yo quería tener
un trabajo de a de veras y cobrar más
que eso y quedarme más d
no me quería quedar 20 años en ese
puesto porque había gente de la empresa
que tenía 30 años haciendo la misma cosa
y yo dije necesito un trabajo de verdad
y entonces puse y renuncie estoy una
maestría y después ya llevo 10 años
regalando dinero ajeno
básicamente haciendo las cuentas como
400 millones de pesos entonces cuando yo
empiezo hablar por teléfono hacia las
instituciones es como lo contrario del
banco o sayana más dicen mi nombre y de
dónde le hablo no de las diferentes
empresas importante contesta entero mira
si no estaba ya llegó y éste
y entonces dije claro y entonces a
partir de ahí empecé a estudiar y empecé
a trabajar pero fue porque me di cuenta
que sin nadie esperaba nada de mí yo sí
esperaba y a partir de ahí me acordé y
después del efecto mariposa no de unas
vacaciones que yo me fue con los amigos
al mar y como siempre en la noche y de
dos sopas los que tienen novia pues se
van con la novia o con el novio y los
que no se van a debería filosofar
y yo estaba en este segundo punto
y entonces un amigo misión dice que le
hubieras dado a la vida que hubieras
hecho por haber nacido normal y le digo
y le digo va al revés imagínate todo lo
que me han dado por haber sido diferente
y entonces no me dijo nada
bueno
y al final de todos estos recuerdos me
di cuenta que no importa si solamente
nos acordamos del 20% de las cosas lo
que importa es que ese 20% sea lo que
merece la pena recordar
[Aplausos]